let's jump into this first big story
it is the end of andrew cuomo
timecast.com reports cuomo quits andrew
cuomo resigns as new york governor over
harassment scandal now here's my
favorite thing about this right he's got
all these women i think 11 women now
have accused him of impropriety one of
them is actually a criminal complaint i
think there may be another criminal
complaint he could potentially get
arrested over this the funniest thing
was and this is what i'm really
fascinated by um
i guess interestingly because of
something your dad actually said
michaela
cuomo's cuomo said he never felt he
crossed the line with these women but he
didn't realize how far the line has
actually moved
so his argument is touching a woman's
face and shoulders and rubbing her elbow
and all that stuff is totally fine and
acceptable but now these women actually
coming out and saying you crossed the
line he's shocked by it now he's
resigning over it so there was an
interview
that
with vice that jordan peterson had where
he mentioned that men and women women
working in the workplace has been a
disaster
and i think what he meant by that was
things like this
i don't necessarily agree if i would use
words that that you know that strongly
but there is a good point to be made
that the line is definitely
not as easily seen perhaps and maybe
that's because people like cuomo are old
and disrespectful i don't know what do
you guys think
they used to smack each other in the
movies like in the 50s guy like what's
his name would backhand a woman and it
was like socially acceptable
crazy how things have changed
i feel it depends what you look like too
yeah i mean maybe if you look like cuomo
people are like don't touch my elbow
like i think that's a big part to play
is that what he got in trouble for was
it just like elbow touching or was it
something like more yeah there's
something more but you know if we say
too much youtube will probably if we
okay yeah
so it was a little bit more oh yeah oh
yeah one i think one of the accusations
is legit like a criminal offense
yeah and he might get arrested for it
but uh hey look innocent until proven
guilty here's the issue that he admitted
it not the most egregious offense he's
denied that but most women like there's
a photo of him holding a woman's face
like he's literally got his hands on her
side of her head okay and then she
claimed he touched her inappropriately
and cuomo was like i never touched her
inappropriately and there's a photo of
him literally holding the woman's head
and i'm like she's like that's not
inappropriate that's really weird yeah i
don't know what year was it how old is
this guy was it when he grew up it was
like a normal thing for dudes to walk up
to home and just grab their heads that's
crazy and that was like a sign of
endearment or something
is that normal i don't think the head
grabbing thing was real i think like a
hand around the waist when you're
walking by or something if you're like
an old dude or like on the shoulder or
something or like maybe on the side of
the head like i can see that coming from
an old man who's just
doesn't know what things are like now
but uh face grab that's a little odd
face grab like like two hands yeah two
hands
i think we talked about it on the show
before too and like we showed the photo
and she's got this look on her face like
i know dear lord help me my face
yeah like oh man the other best part
about it is that when he was defending
himself a few days ago he plays this
video where he's like i do it to
everybody if you're white if you're
black if you're gay or straight a man or
a woman and he's showing videos of him
grabbing people's heads okay like
i feel like that's fair then he's like
it's just my thing i don't know
just because he does it to everybody i
don't i don't think makes it no it
doesn't make it it doesn't matter it
makes it worse oh it makes it worse okay
i think it makes it better really
yeah i mean it's not good for him and
it's probably not a good social thing to
do as a person but like then it's you're
not special lady so wasn't his defense
um i'm italian because that seems i feel
like that's also i feel like that's also
a good excuse that's part of it that
could be that i'm italian i'm old and i
do it to everyone is that can we confirm
that that he that he said that it's not
don't blame me blame the attack blame
the italians
i know that he mentioned it i don't know
if it was actually his defense that i
was like what dude i know italians like
to talk with her kiss each other yeah
yeah but i get that yeah i totally get
that
but it's like
i don't know dude that might be a little
bit too much and if people are giving
you signs like as you're getting older
you need to be paid maybe you don't care
though i mean haven't you noticed like
the older you get the older you get the
less you care can you imagine what
happens when you hit like
that how old is he 64.
yeah he's over 60. i guess i guess he
said i'm an over 60 italian american
male
the boston globe says that is not a
defense for harassment
it's really not though okay
but to be fair things have definitely
changed the lines have moved like girls
can now
take you in for anything like if you put
i feel weird when people put their hand
on my waist i find that to be strange
lower back yeah like lower back like i
find that to be a little bit weird like
please don't do that to me
i feel like that's always made people
feel a little weird though that's i
don't think the line like
i can't well i'm not sure i think it
depends on how the guy looks
i think you might be right about that
too like if you've seen that cartoon
where it's like this really ugly guy and
she's like oh it's sexual harassment and
then the same thing happens with this
really good looking guy yeah oh hey
what's going on you know yeah go out for
dinner or whatever it's totally
different i don't know women are really
kind of strange and touchy now too
though so it might be like way different
especially for yeah people have gotten
touchier for sure
women have always been strange though
that's true hands on the waist is like
opportunity it's like a it's like an act
of opportunity for a guy from my
perspective it definitely is like you're
going you're crossing the line it feels
like
like you're this like wild beast and
i can't i can't condone that i was i was
raised though so maybe that's why i
think that we we have this uh the
comments that's the comic book i'm
talking about yeah it's uh it's this
like suave looking guy with a tennis
ball and it's like looking good susan
and she says oh you're so you're sweet
yeah and the next one is like a chubby
portly guy and he says looking good
susan and she says hello human resources
the funny thing about this is mad
magazine made a similar comic a long
time ago it's a mad look at public it
was a mad look at love or something like
that i can remember i remember reading
when i was a kid and it shows two
beautiful looking people and they're
like kissing in public i think that's
what i've seen and then everyone's going
like oh
and the next panel was two fat people
doing it everyone's like all angry
there's something really interesting
about it though when you mention like
the hand on the back or whatever like is
that sexual
is it is it is the man walking with a
woman and like putting his hand on the
small of her back and like guiding her
forward is he doing that as some kind of
like
perverse or sexual action or says yes i
wouldn't say i don't know perverse but i
would say if like whenever that's been
done to me i've been like i get that
kind of like what's going on yeah it's
not like you know maybe upper back maybe
that's like kind of guiding but anything
like lower back i at least have the
bodily response of like okay what's
happening here and i think that's
because that's not often touched and i
think that's just the bottom line
putting your hands on someone's face to
me that's really weird like that's a
strange crossing if you put your hand on
60 year old italians though all the time
i don't know man i don't know cuomo
grabbing some ladies
i mean you can handshake is fine a high
five is cool yeah a hug if you both
like want to but
that so there are different ways that
you can hug somebody too like you don't
usually you don't usually hug a guy like
full on up front up close hug him like a
triangle or whatever whatever you want
to do or on one side but it's how do you
hug like a triangle you just like keep
your lower bodies apart oh you like lean
your chest
yeah
it's not like he's grabbing her head but
he's got his hands like under her
on her neck yeah and he's holding up
sorry but he's got this weird lip biting
thing going on at the same time yeah
[Laughter]
you know what bothers me about this is
that people are it feels like people are
piling on i don't like this this
behavior where one person comes out and
is like he he aggressed on me and then
and then two more and then three more
and then all of a sudden there's 11
people
and like i don't want to set a precedent
or or continue a precedent that it's
okay to pile on well why not i mean
if if these women are scared to speak up
because he's powerful he's cuomo and
then one woman finally says look what he
did and then another woman feels
comfortable now because she feels she
wouldn't be alone in this like someone
broke the barrier so that others could
come forward yeah and it comes out like
a a damn breaking right it's tricky
because sometimes you have that for
popularity right like oh it also
happened to me and then you get your
name in the news and so check me too
yeah yeah kind of like that but but also
i think just as human beings especially
if they're not outspoken ones it's
really hard to be the first to do
something and so you could easily be
being like well maybe i'm the only one
no one's going to believe me maybe it'll
just go away type of thing although it's
just like a hand a head hold
so here's
there's something like it's not yet
although there's worse apparently yeah
there is something uh interesting here
though that i think
we need to consider when it comes to men
and women working in the same place
i don't think there will ever be a
circumstance where there could be
true social equality in the sense not
like workplace like uh career or or
revenue but just what you can or cannot
say to a man and woman will never be
equal right
what two men can say to each other they
will never be allowed to say between a
man and woman what two women can say to
each other they can't say to men so one
example would be like the one i always
give is if uh two guys are like you know
coming into work one guy's in the
elevator and then the other guy walks in
and he goes oh damn that's a new suit
huh man you get that tailored you're
looking cut so you got a new haircut too
man punches him in the shoulder or pats
him on the shoulder or what if he says
like stop sexy
yeah i say that that's what i said yeah
yeah
so so but but i think the issue of
complimenting a guy's new tailored suit
like wow jim new suit looking killer
that is amazing you get that specially
done plus the haircut man it's working
really well that's a guy complimenting
being like you're looking sharp man
totally fine now imagine the woman walks
in wearing a dress
did you get that dress tailored that is
looking sharp wow i love what you're
doing with this look
the sirens are going on all
all of a sudden it's like whoa
does it depend okay i agree first of all
i agree and i think for the majority of
women it would be weird i think that
there are certain
types of personalities
that would be able to work with men i
don't think it's the average woman
though i'm kind of in agreement there i
think there's well like obviously men
and women can work together but there's
going to be some weird dynamic and
you're going to be like is this going to
be offensive or how is this going to be
taken what can i say exactly
i personally i'll tell people this so i
have a team of people
everybody who works for me right now are
men
and i used to my best friend used to
work with me and she's a girl and that
was fine but we're like very similar
people pretty disagreeable and i could
tell her whatever and she's not offended
by anything
but i've noticed if i hire someone and
they're female
i have to be careful about how i talk to
them uh even give giving criticism i
like i i feel like and maybe it's me but
i feel like i have to be a little bit
nicer a little bit more gentler whereas
with a dude i can be like can you just
not do this again and they're like yeah
no problem won't do it again but if it's
female i'm like okay you did like this a
little bit wrong here's how to do it a
little bit better overall you're doing a
great job everything's fine please don't
be upset this is no this is really
interesting i remember reading there was
a study about gender discrimination in
the workplace that found
women female bosses are equally as
likely to discriminate as a male boss
yeah maybe if not more but it was just
equal
i think it said something like it was
equal as likely like the issue wasn't um
that the gender the gender of the boss
the issue was the behavior of the
employees and then there was like a
tendency among women like more
agreeableness and things like that which
resulted in
the more like executive stern types to
behave in a specific way that was
not related to to gender or you know
whatever yeah that doesn't surprise me
at all i think a lot of that's
personality yeah
and i i think you're completely right
because i am like you said i am the kind
of person who wants to know how i can
improve not just that i did something
wrong so please like give me positive
feedback and be like all right so you
did well with this did well with this
this needs work and this is fine so i
think that that management style of like
two you know a positive negative and
positive like the sandwich is very much
like a feminine thing and trying to
protect yes i think that's a good
management style anyway it just takes
more effort than just being like look i
don't i like you as a person it's not
offensive it's just can you fix this
next time right and then instead of
having somebody soul crushed
do you think that like behavior
transcends gender that and that because
i know jordan talks a lot about this i
mean i'm obsessed with that guy what's
up dude
like
that that men and women have like
intrinsic
you know behavioral patterns not that
every woman has it but that women are
more you know nurturing and mentally
more into things women are more to
people
but does that is that it's not always
the case obviously there are people that
that transcend that that dichotomy
and i wonder if you know especially with
the what we're the age of like a
thousand genders and and
heteronormativity and and what do you
call it post-modernism
like maybe there's something maybe maybe
we're all becoming like genderless
you know babies and test tubes
i don't think so i mean i think i think
society is changing in a way that
encourages certain behaviors and stuff
but
testosterone plays a role man and a lot
of things
i think people are getting sicker and
that's part of the problem interesting
like i think that if you're on i mean i
don't know what percentage of the
population is on some sort of like psych
med at the moment or on
yeah and since covet has gotten worse
and those things have like they make
people different than they are so i
think people like obviously people are
getting sick one in five people have an
autoimmune disorder people are gaining
weight like mad and i think that comes
with mental problems and i think that
screws up your behavior including
probably the more normal
like feminine and masculine behavior
it's interlinked i think i think people
who are living unhealthy lives are more
likely to have some kind of illness that
requires medication which then in turn
creates this cycle of
addiction and
endless ailment i suppose thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time